>> IT'S TIME TO PLAY YAHOO
ANSWERS, PARANORMAL EDITION.
YAHOO ANSWERS IS A GREAT WAY TO
GET COMPLETELY INCORRECT
INFORMATION FROM ALL KINDS OF
RANDOM PEOPLE.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HELL
THEY DO ON YAHOO.
I'M GOING TO READ A REAL
QUESTION ABOUT THE PARANORMAL,
AND IF YOUR ANSWER IS BETTER
THAN OUR FAVORITE YAHOO ANSWER
YOU GET 250 POINTS.
HERE'S THE FIRST ONE.
I CAN GET A GHOST PREGNANT?
MOSHE?
>> YES, BUT THEN YOU HAVE TO GET
THE FETUS GHOST BUSTED.
( APPLAUSE )
( CHEERS )
>> LET'S SEE WHAT THE ACTUAL
ANSWER WAS.
THIS IS ACTUALLY MORE COMMON
THAN YOU THINK.
THEY'RE JUST RARELY SEEN AS THEY
ARE INVISIBLE.
THIS GUY KNOWS A LOT ABOUT SEX
FOR A VIRGIN.
>> ALL RIGHT, GOOD COMEBACK.
I'LL GIVE YOU POINTS FOR THAT
MOSHE KASHER.
HERE'S THE NEXT ONE-- A REAL
HAUPTED FLASH POSSESSED DOLL ON
E-BAY.
DO YOU THINK BUYING THIS ONE A
GOOD IDEA?
>> IT DEPENDS.
ARE YOU BUYING IT FOR DECORATION
OR SEX?
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE ).
>> I LIKE YOUR ODDS SO FAR.
LET'S SEE WHAT THE REAL ANSWER
IS.
THE REAL ANSWER IS, "IF YOU WANT
IT, BUY IT."
A TERRIBLE ANSWER.
POINTS TO STEVE AGEE!
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
NEXT ONE-- HOW DO I TELL MY MOM
SHE'S POSSESSED WITHOUT HURTING
HER FEELINGS?
MOSHE.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO WANT TO USE
"EYE" STATEMENTS INSTEAD OF
"YOU" STATEMENTS.
FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN YOU PROJECTILE
VOMIT AND ( BLEEP ) YOURSELF
WITH A CRUCIFIX, I FEEL I'M
LOVED.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> LET'S SEE.
LET'S SEE WHAT THE ACTUAL ANSWER
WAS.
HIRE A PRIEST TO COME IN AND
PERFORM AN EXORICISM.
HOWEVER, DO NOT LET HER KNOW
BEFOREHAND BECAUSE THER
POSSESSED SPIRIT MAY RUN WITH
THE BOBODIY.
MOSHE KASHER, I DO BELIEVE YOU
GOT POINTS FOR THAT.
LAST ONE, CAN A GHOST PET A CAT?
( LAUGHTER )
YES, STEVE AGEE?
>> GO ( BLEEP ) YOURSELF, LOSER.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> I DON'T CARE WHAT THE REAL
ANSWER IS.